in this video we're going to talk about
how to classify pols by the degree as
well as the number of terms so let's
kind of go through what exactly is a
polom well a polinomial it's a sum or
difference of monomials what's a
monomial well monomial is basically like
a number or a variable or a product of a
number and a variable to a positive uh
integer exponent so you don't want to
have negative exponents or fraction
exponents you don't want the variable in
the denominator you don't want uh you
don't want something like this where the
variable is in the exponent position
that's not a polinomial so you want to
think about uh a sum or difference of
monomials so let's go through the
different terminology here so the number
of terms the terms are separated by plus
or minus a term is basically like a
group and so if you only have one group
we call that a monomial for example like
5x but if you have two terms we call
that a binomial kind of like bicy call
right by for two and you can see they're
separated by that plus or minus sign so
an example might be like 2x + 1 a
trinomial there's three terms 1 two
three again separated by a minus or plus
uh this would be another example of a
trinomial and then a polinomial that has
four terms we can just call it a
polinomial with four terms or a
polinomial with five terms or polinom
with six terms but when it's just one
two or three have a special name
monomial binomial trinomial so that's
classifying it by the number of terms
how do we classify it by the degree now
the degree is whatever the highest uh
exponent or that highest power is so if
it's a zeroth degree we call that a
constant this is sometimes referred to
as the type and if it's Zer degree that
just means it's like a number like seven
or five or two but if it's a first
degree the type is linear and again you
can see this is like a line and see how
it's that's to the first uh Power the
first degree now if it's a second degree
we call it a quadratic see how 3x^2 + 2
that highest exponent is a two third
degree we say cubic 5x cubed as an
example fourth degree quartic see again
that highest power is four fifth degree
we call it quintic highest exponent here
is five see this one's two but you go
with the highest one and then after that
you could just say sixth degree 7th
degree 8th degree Etc Nth Degree so it's
got two names kind of like a first and a
last name let's go through these 10
examples you might want to try and pause
the video or take a screenshot see if
you can do these and we'll go through
them so for number one what do you think
here F ofx = 2x - 3x^2 + 4 notice that
highest power is a 2 so we're thinking
okay it's going to be a quadratic how
many terms does it have 1 two three so
we call it a quadratic trinomial okay
let's try number two what do you think
for this one F ofx = 7 - 3x 4th power
well again you can see the highest
exponent is four this is like Zero's
degree that's fourth degree four is the
highest so we're thinking quartic two
terms remember the terms are separated
by minus or plus so we're thinking
binomial so I would say this is a
quartic binomial let's go to number
three F ofx = 6X cubed again this
highest power is three so we're thinking
cubic only one term here we're thinking
monomial so I would say cubic monomial
for number four 5x - one highest degree
is one so we're thinking linear like a
line two terms that's a binomial so I
would say a linear
binomial for number five what do you
think for this one well now this one see
it's not in standard form usually want
to write it from the highest power down
to the lowest so it looks like our
highest power term is this guy right
here notice that degree is five so we're
going to call it a
quintic polom with four terms okay let's
go to number six f ofx equals 7 I
actually had that one right here so this
is a constant because it's just zeroth
degree and it's a monomial so you could
say constant monomial number seven seven
we have two terms so that's a binomial
like bicycle right two wheels and the
highest power is six so we would say
this is a 6 Dee
binomial uh for number eight what do you
think here highest power looks like it's
three so we're looking at a cubic 1 2 34
so a cubic polinomial with four terms uh
number nine we have 12x this is just one
term this is a monomial is to the first
degree which means that it's a linear so
I would say a linear monomial and then
the last one what do you think for this
one highest exponent is four we have 1
two three terms so it's a trinomial so I
would call it a quartic see fourth
degree cortic
trinomial so great job if you're able to
get these problems if you want to see
more examples follow me over to a video
I did there talking about pols and
classifying them I'll see over in that
video